continuamos con más información aquí en
fra 24 y es tiempo de hablar de economía
estamos para eso con daniela blandón
stand y la bienvenida y empezamos en
eeuu porque el país comenzó a aliviar
las sanciones en contra de venezuela
hola a liliana el anuncio lo hizo el
departamento del tesoro que autorizó a
las empresas no estadounidenses hasta
julio de 2022 a que envíen a venezuela
sin riesgo de sanciones gas licuado de
petróleo más conocido como gas propano
paradójicamente liliana en venezuela
siendo el país con las mayores reservas
de petróleo del mundo la escasez de gas
hoy en día hace que muchos tengan que
cocinar con leña los envíos de
combustible y en general cualquier
transacción de empresas con la estatal
pedevesa habían sido prohibidos mediante
varias órdenes ejecutivas firmadas entre
2018 y 2019 por el entonces presidente
de donald trump por eso el desbloqueo al
menos de las compras de gas propano es
considerado un esperado primer paso en
un eventual cambio de política de la
administración joe biden hacia venezuela
momentos en que el presidente nicolás
maduro también ha dado ciertos pasos
para tratar de mostrar mensajes
conciliadores con washington
daniela y el hambre en el mundo durante
el año 2020 hay un informe anual de
naciones unidas que dice que hubo un
empeoramiento dramático de este flagelo
durante el primer año de pandemia
alrededor de una décima parte de la
población es decir unos 811 millones de
personas estaban desnutridas del año
pasado en parte como consecuencia por
supuesto del cob y de 19 esto es de 118
millones más que en 2019
sólo en américa latina' se evidenció un
aumento del 9,1 por ciento de la
población con desnutrición en el año
tenemos tres mil millones de personas
que no tienen acceso a dieta saludable
este negocio en aumento significativo en
el retraso de crecimiento sobrepeso y
obesidad vieron si no cambiamos la forma
en que operamos en los sistemas
agroalimentarios no podremos alcanzar
los objetivos de desarrollo sostenible
en 2030 a nivel de unión europea
suspendió sus planes para gravar a las
grandes empresas tecnológicas en un
gesto de buena voluntad hacia eeuu que
se ha opuesto al debate sobre gravámenes
a los gigantes digitales en lo que se
conoce como 'tasa google' bruselas
quiere concentrarse en finalizar la
histórica decisión fiscal respaldada el
fin de semana en italia por los
ministros de finanzas del g20 esto sobre
un impuesto global corporativo de al
menos un 15%
hicimos grandes avances en la discusión
global sobre cómo podemos grabar mejor a
las empresas el paso más importante es
que tenemos un acuerdo sobre un impuesto
mínimo global que también tenemos uno
sobre cómo grabar mejor a las grandes
empresas de alta rentabilidad incluidas
aquellas que están activas como gigantes
digitales globales esta medida de la que
estamos hablando busca poner piso a las
tasas impositivas en todo el mundo y
también disuadir a las empresas de usar
paraísos fiscales pero todavía requiere
una discusión más amplia los líderes del
g20 lo van a discutir en su próxima
reunión que tendrá lugar en octubre de
este año el día 4 de los indicadores de
la jornada
bueno wall street cerró con un triple
récord histórico el dow jones el
standard and poor's y el índice nasdaq
todos se vieron favorecidos en la
antesala de una nueva temporada de
resultados financieros que arranca este
martes con los grandes bancos reportando
cómo les fue en el primer semestre y las
bolsas de américa latina también
iniciaron la semana en positivo
especialmente la de buenos aires
después de que el gobierno anunciara
nuevas restricciones a la compra de
dólares esto para frenar la devaluación
de su moneda local la nieve y la ciudad
el día cuéntenos liliana 17 38 por
ciento esto cayó la acción de virgin
galactic en un wall street un día
después de completar su primer vuelo de
prueba con tripulación al espacio con el
fundador multimillonario richard branson
abordó la caída de la acción de virgin
galactic del lunes es irrisoria si se
tiene en cuenta que en el año ha subido
más del 80 por ciento analistas
atribuyen el descenso al anuncio de que
sacará 500 millones de acciones de
dólares en acciones a la venta wall
street pero también a que muchos
esperaban que se reabriera la venta de
boletos para ir al espacio en cambio
branson anunció un sorteo de apenas dos
asientos más ya 600 personales y liliana
han presentado su cupo turístico con
tiquetes que costaron 250 mil dólares
cada uno
gracias daniela yo estoy gracias
continúen con base en 324 puntocom
[Música]